[Musique]
dix mille salavaux qui jean rouyer
famille m
kb
m
[Musique]
pour les téléspectateurs
téléspectatrices qui vous connaissent un
peu moins
spécifions que le monde libération le
point parle de vous quelle est votre
réaction parce que votre dernier album
m'a vraiment impressionné les critiques
oui ça va plus on prie je suis hyper
contente que tous ces médias utilisés su
comprendre l'album un album qui pas
nécessairement tout évident à comprendre
le nucléaire
[Musique]
vous êtes né à montréal de parents
haïtiens qui ont fui le régime de papa
doc dans toute jeune qu'est ce qu'on
vous a appris à propos d'ali un parent
ou voulait très peu parlé en fait c'est
marrant parce que mon enfant ça a été un
mélange de transmission passive une
transmission active 3 / attention active
c'est soit faire deux tahitiennes a ici
c'est le premier pays et première
république noire qui fait libérer de
l'esclavagé qui en signe de ribaute et
cinq autres pays de l'esclavagé en
amérique du sud et du coup mon père me
faisait rire lire et relire napoléon
noir un ouvrage qui est culture sur
l'ouverture et des salines et ensuite
transition passive c'est 7 7
cette tristesse est ce la nostalgie du
pays que mes parents m'ont transmis sans
vouloir le dire parce que les parents
ils ont ils ont tellement pas envie de
nous montrer qu'ils sont tristes mais
ils ont tellement triste que mon
permanent il habite vraiment
moitié-moitié au canada et on a ici
parce que le pays est à manquer pendant
les quarante ans qu'ils ont vécu ici
[Musique]
depuis 2011 vous êtes fasciné par ces
chansons traditionnels haïtiens composer
entre 1915 et 1934 sous l'occupation
américaine
qu'est-ce qui vous intéressait dans ces
chansons là c'est l'humour haïtien lourd
à issia qui est très pointue qui sait
pas il ya quelque chose qui est très
particulier avec l'humour haïtien et on
le retrouve dans ces chansons là après
ça il ya ce côté sur le vaudou qui a
toujours servi comme comme une arme de
résistance en ce moment avec la
dépendance d'haïti en 1804
mais aussi avec l'occupation américaine
où ses chansons elle on va en fait peur
ou ceux d'anne k tellement peur qu'ils
ont essayé de réparer c'est l'expression
du monde
ils voudraient y faire un petit haïtien
et pratiquent pas le voodoo il fait
partie de delà du quotidien des haïtiens
que le budo et c'est une région qui a
vachement accepter les personnes
transgenres les personnes quid des gains
liés parce qu'il ya une sorte
d'acceptation que ces personnes sont des
personnes qui que nous en tant que
personne cru à une personne qui est on a
une sorte de connexion entre le plus
privilégié aux esprits
[Musique]
mais dans le boude ou en tout cas ces
personnes là nous on est là q je
trouvais ça manière pour moi de me
réconcilier avec mon pays où j'ai eu
peur d'y aller vous saisir tant que
lesbienne
peut-être que les gens m'ont pas mal
acceptée et en fait ça s'est passé comme
j'irai pas une lettre à la poste s'est
très bien passé j'ai ressenti le sentit
bien accueilli vous en avez peut-être
entendu parler ici une production un
spectacle bâti cela qui reprend les
chants d'esclaves
avez vous une opinion à lathus sur cette
controverse
oui moi je dis dédieront d'août par
rapport à radio si mal par exemple je
suis peut-être pas assez ancien pour
reprendre tes chansons six mois en tant
qu à une chienne j'ai des doutes
j'aurais pensé que tu vas nous faire si
robert lepage estime possible un peu
plus des questions et j'ai trouvé aussi
les concerts de betty bonifassi en
disant ah mais en fait moi j'ai pas de
couleurs pour moi moi je vois la couleur
la couleur c'est pas un c'est un crime
de voir de la couleur la couleur c'est
si nos origines à tout le monde et c'est
une reconnaissance du passé c'est une
reconnaissance de l'histoire si on
efface les couleurs en fait on y fasse
l'histoire des gens et c'est triste
parce qu'on efface aussi les peines et
tout ce que tout ce qu'elle est juste
que nous a amenés jusqu'à ici sont 10es
tout d'un coup a bien joué pas la
couleur de tes parents mais mes parents
ils ont vécu une histoire atroce en
haïti ce serait horrible de passer à
travers ça donc moi je sais c'est pas le
spectacle en lui-même c'est la forme
c'est le discours qu'il ya derrière
qu'il m'a qui m'a paru un peu un peu
violent mais le salagou
mais si en plus il est atypique
je suis là fut jamais
[Musique]